it was supposed to be one of the most
magical nights of the couple's lives but
in the middle of their wedding
celebrations happiness instinctly turned
it into horror
Fire tour through the packed Hall
Witnesses describe the venue catching
fire in seconds
slow they were about to do a slow dance
and then they lit up this thing for the
dance which caught fire
many who survived the chart by severe
burns and in serious condition
I came to the hospital and after a while
they called me and I was told that 22
members of my family are burned
so I came here and searched for them and
once I found them they were transferred
to mosul as their condition was critical
it happened in the minority Christian
region of the Nineveh province in
Northern Iraq
State media reported the building was
made of Highly flammable materials
I was sitting with my family inside the
banquet hall when I saw a flame erupt
from the fireworks I immediately took my
family and ran out but I lost my mother
she was in the bathroom when the blaze
broke out and it was too late to save
her the entire Place burned to the
ground in seconds
officials say the fire is being
investigated
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera